does anything change because you're now
doing a commercial with the sexiest man
alive I'm doing this one naked after
getting sexiest man alive
he just wore a suit with no shirt yeah
it's pretty pretty shocking and I'm back
to normal no it was pretty cool that he
got it and then I was like we everyone
on the voice gets it so I think that's
why you signed up for the boys that was
the reason mm-hmm John ad-libs a lot and
Chrissy gets to wear a feathered white
gown in the Superbowl commercial for the
launch of the first-ever SUV from
Genesis the gv8 II what's the magic word
sexiest man alive okay the Genesis is
the youngest luxury car brand in the
world
can you tell me one secret from the
commercial rolling rolling very quiet I
think the biggest shocker is that we're
actually gonna be driving it somebody
had to make luxury fun people do these
commercials they don't eat what they're
eating in the commercials no no those
girls at eating those burgers none of
those girls are like you'll also see
John Chrissy Luna and Myles cruising
around with the newest addition to their
family this adorable puppy PD the poodle
John successfully talked to out of the
name Kitty which she wanted to call him
kitty yeah I just felt like it wasn't
gonna mesh why didn't she call you John
I was taking her to school this morning
and she said it again and she laughed so
she knows it's a thing she's not
supposed to do it but now she's just
messed with when she gets a laugh she's
a lot
she's a lot like this one
[Music]